[Music]
you did a Salette body grooming campaign
yeah and in which you're sort of
advocating men grooming everywhere is
that something is it was that just you
were just doing that as a commercial or
is that something you actually believe
in I for me I think when you've gotten
to that point at the night or the day
depending on who you are I don't think
it really quite matters you know you
kind of like who you like I think
there's that weird thing though if
someone takes too much care it can be
weird it's creepy right
it's creepy especially if a guy has got
like topiary forms down there book in
someone's house and it was um celebrity
hairstyles for your that's what it was
it was the strangest thing I've ever
like no I didn't I didn't mind it when
he was saying that word I'm actually in
that book yeah
I remember I felt like the Howard Stern
and it was so traumatizing to see what
it would look like Oh different
celebrity styles yeah I'm pretty sure
that the Conan into some guy walking out
there rocking the Conan thinking that's
gonna you know impress the ladies
thinking it's going to impress the lady
you might yeah he's just this down there
yeah that would be fantastic what I
thought was crazy about is that you know
young guys will do a lot of things to
impress girls and I was like it's a joke
book I'm hope what if they came across
it and thought it was serious and like
picked they're like girls favorite
celebrity and like carved it out I feel
like I could have like really
traumatized a lot of young girls anyway
that's my big concern about celebrity
you've taken on an important cause
[Applause]
we gotta get this baby pigs pen